so we've all experienced that feeling
when you're really connecting with
somebody right you meet somebody new
they're really exciting you find
yourself hypnotized by their presence
you find them bewitching and as you
start to converse as you start to share
stories you find that you come into this
synchronized kind of element you feel
like you're connected you feel like
you're meshing you feel like you're on
the same vibe like you're on the same
frequency and I love that we use these
ambiguous terminology to describe what
is experientially at least a
metaphysical experience I mean what does
that even mean oh man we were machine we
were connected we were so vibing it's
almost like these musical metaphors to
describe something that ultimately can't
be measured but our intuition alone is
the way in which we come to realize that
we're having that experience of somebody
else but again it's not like we have
like a radar machine that can scan when
we're synchronized with somebody else oh
I'm meshing with her her radar meter of
meshing was really working you know we
have technological instruments to
measure radar and measure F you know
other electromagnetic spectrum
frequencies you know but we don't have
instruments to do that when it comes to
the space of human interaction and yet
we have these experiences they feel real
right they're there they're intuitive
they're there they're subjective and so
what does that mean so recently there
was a researcher at Ted who was doing
some research on what he calls brain
coupling and what he did is he actually
did fMRI scans on the brains of like
romantic couples or best friends or
people that you feel like they kind of
speak each other's language and so
here's what's really interesting when he
did fMRI scans on the brain so like an
empirical scientific measurement of what
was happening in each of their brains he
found that their brain waves were
actually synchronizing so take that in
for a second a metaphysical experience a
supposedly non-measurable metaphysical
magical dimension of the human
experience in which you aren't meshing
and connecting and by v and then on the
same frequency with somebody else that
poetic rapturous subjective experience
all of a sudden can be quantified in an
empirical scientific manner
so we are grounding the poetry the
mystery of human communication of human
intimacy and finally able to like
understand it in a physical sense in a
physical way and so when science finally
sort of grounds or metaphysical musings
in an empirical reality what it does for
me is it doesn't get rid of the mystery
but it sort of reassures me that what I
was experiencing was real it sort of
makes it even more real for me so now I
know that when I meet that special
someone when she comes into my life and
she smiles in just the right way and I
get the goosebumps from tear staring at
the iris of a lovers eye I know that our
brain waves are literally in sync and so
this is what we should look for when we
connect with anybody we should be like
hey you want a brain couple with me you
want to sit and talk and get naked and
body and mind then couple our brain
waves together because that's what I'm
interested in skip this small stop skip
the small talk and go to straight to
that like inner subjective rapture let's
become one thing I mean this is the goal
this is intimacy this is what we so
desperately want to articulate but often
fail to do ah
anyway that's brain coupling
you